yo yo yo welcome back to the edge with
your boy Michael Parsons live in your
Bleacher Report app hope everyone had a
happy New Year um I hope your new year
was full of love um cherishing moments
and people that you just love to be
around with and I hope it was a
cherishable moment going into 20124 um
claim your year claim your day claim
your week claim it all claim this is
going to be
it let's get straight to it oh my gosh
it was a great football weekend for all
my football junkies it couldn't have
getting better than that a lot of games
down to the wire a lot of blowouts uh
college football was even even more
crazier I mean let's just get straight
into it and we're going to start out
with our recap Lions Cowboys if you
didn't watch it it was a monsters game
great game um we're still healing from
that game it was a hardfought game I
think for both sides but obviously what
came up the most is the com obviously
the controversy at the end of the game
and I'm just going to let it know right
now when the ref came up to me and for
some reason I was kind of like on edge
that a play like that was already
happening um but when 68 caught it I did
not think he was eligible the line the
ref reported that 70 was eligible he
reported him eligible uh majority of the
game so therefore you know when it
happened when the flag was stoned I was
not surprised but I was surprised they
went for it again after I jumped offside
that was kind of
like wow but at the same time I guess in
their mindset we already clenched their
div they already clinched their division
um they kind of have nothing else to
lose um so it's just kind of like we
want to beat them and uh any means
possible so you know uh I'm not
surprised by it at all I think that was
a it was a great game um whatever how
however they feel uh Dan Campbell said
he drew it up with the officials before
the game game but when they reported
they reported that 70 was eligible and
that's the end of the story um it
happens like that and at this point we
got to move on you win some you lose
some um but it was a great game um and
you know it was some great football play
out anyways outside of that Jimmy
Johnson was ducked into the Cowboys Ring
of Honor at halftime Super great uh
super happy for Jimmy Johnson everything
he could contribute to the Cowboys
country Cowboys Nation uh great game I
mean he's a legend and I'm super happy
for him to finally be in a Ring of Honor
uh you see how many people love and
cherish that man uh he's super great
Jerry Jones also said he hosts this
within the Super Bowl drought do you
agree um I you know I don't believe in
uh that type of Karma and whatever
Voodoo um that could have over I think
the people in the locker room and the
people uh that plays kind of contradicts
the game you know I don't really believe
into the extra analytics of outside
noise maybe for his personal thing but
you know to me it's all about how we
play and how great we going to be and
how how good our defense going to be um
my man CD lamb set two Cowboys franchise
records in the game he passed Michael
Irving for the most catches and the most
receiving yards in the season he was
selected for the drug test but it
doesn't even matter we know he's clean
that CD M lamb the best receiver in NFL
not top five not top three he's top two
not two and I think he's putting on the
show and it wasn't for them that little
drought period that he before he had to
show that he's always open he arguably
would have broke the record uh I don't
care what nobody say CD's a a boss he's
a number one receiv um and you know if
it wasn't for Christian McCaffrey's year
that he's having um who's arguably going
up for MVP right now is going back and
forth but I think Lamar just solidified
himself as MVP he probably should be
offensive player of the year um him and
Christian Tyreek is having uh some of
the best seasons that you know anyone
could ever see in the NFL um one of the
three best weapons um bro it it's just
been off the chain for the uh them three
this year but uh you know CD's arguably
right there he has one more game
Christian sitting out to try to go claim
that um and let's see how he does in
that standpoint but CD lamb
congratulations brother you are truly
shown why you're the number one a lot of
people a lot of naysayers there was a
lot of naysayers I remember Richard
Sherman early in the year said he wasn't
even a top five receiver
whatever A lot of people said he
couldn't be a number one when Amar
Cooper was gone um but CD still here he
just continuously to get better
continuously just keep proving people
wrong and he's having a year of his life
and he's going to have a big big payday
coming soon so uh the drip God is going
to be shining shining bling bling again
real real soon um but let's get right
into it a lot of her a lot of downplay
on Lamar Jackson season yes his stats
may not be the best but he is winning
games he's playing great football and
people forget when you have these leads
and you have this great defense you
don't always have to put the team on
your back but when the ball is in hand
great things happen and last week on Fox
a radio spoke a radio host mon balanos
said Lamar Jackson shouldn't be MVP
because quote I want my quarterbacks to
be quarterbacking and to me Lamar
Jackson is just a great athlete and this
is my point right if you're in the NFL
and you're playing a quarterback Lamar
Jackson's already won an MVP the only
thing he's missing is a Super Bowl Lamar
Jackson is a solidified quarterback in
this league I don't care if you're
quarterback I don't care if you're a
great athlete that's like saying LeBron
James can't be the greatest basketball
player because he's not the greatest
shooter or he's not the he's not like
he's not the best dunker he's just a
great athlete no LeBron James is one of
the arguably the greatest basketball
players to ever touched feet on a court
I don't care what period or whatever
wherever you put however you want to put
things man you are it doesn't matter I
don't believe in your athlete you're
just a skilled position whatever you're
a dog whatever you played the game at an
extremely high level Lamar Jackson is a
quarterback when you look up his name
when you draft him he was a quarterback
I don't care what type of category you
try to put Lamar Jackson in he is one of
the best quarterbacks if not the best
quarterback and probably just to let him
cified himself as an MVP and this year
in the NFL this year I mean it you
you'll have a dominant win against
arguably you know the Miami Dolphins who
upset uh upset us last week and you go
do that I mean Lamar like come on bro
and then the stats he had it was just it
was just breathtaking bro he was just on
a whole another level um so
congratulations Lamar the Steelers
defense is coming to try to put rain on
his to raade but they're probably
finished their uh season strong they're
the number one team in the AFC which is
extremely important um locked it in so
they are going to have a lot of rest
time but man oh man Lamar Jackson is
playing unbelievably right now um and
they just keep proving people wrong you
know obviously them back toback wins
against you know playoff caliber teams I
mean the both playoff teams obviously
the 49ers are number one team in the NFC
and wherever the Dolphins is going to be
they're going to be a top seed um you
know the backto back moments back toback
blowouts and you know these is MVP I
mean these is people that's been
involved in MVP conversations Tu was
involved in MVP conversations br P was
the leader of the MVP conversation
before he played Lamar and Lamar just
walked through both of them I mean this
is this is It's just mind blocking what
he's doing right now how good the Ravens
are the Ravens are arguably about to
have the best defense that anyone's ever
seen before they're going to talk about
this defense for years to come I mean
years to come the way roquan and P
Patrick Queen's playing right now it's
unbelievable I mean and then the way
this offense is clicking down Mark
Andrews Isaiah likely stepping up
they're putting theel as the best team
in the NFL right now with the 49ers
right there playoffs is going to be very
interesting playoffs is going to be
great great I think this going to be one
of the best playoffs uh that people seen
in a while and you know obviously I hope
my D Cowboys come out on top but Ravens
defense they're allowing 16.3 points a
game uh 26 takeaway 54 sacks they're
leading everything going to the last
week this def this is like historic Ray
Lewis like stuff right here like this is
crazy what they're accomplishing overall
they're a great team I mean and and it's
fun to see I honestly I love watching
them um you know Patrick Queen and ran
uh and if you notice every top team they
have Elite linebacker play and I I think
that's something that can go unmissed I
think linebackers should get way more
value because look who's leading East
team Drake green law Fred Warner is
leading the 49ers the Ravens got Patrick
Queen Ro ran Smith leading the uh Ravens
two top defenses I mean you look at
before the Bills lost Matt Milano Matt
Milanos was one of the best linebackers
in the NFL and you see how far they
dropped um and how things fell off when
he
left linebacker play is extremely
important in NFL and it should not go
onmed um you need extremely talented
linebackers it it's just it's
unbelievable what these them two teams
are doing right there in their
linebacker play probably both going to
be all pro linebackers this year let's
get into the AFC East bill playoff
scenario heading into the final week if
the bills wins they clinch the AFC East
but if they lose and the Steelers beat
the Ravens who just clinch the number
one seat the Jags beat the Titans do not
end in the tie they will miss playoffs
so this could be a very dangerous
situation for the bills this is a much
one have it don't even leave it up to
chance because the Steelers have beat
the Ravens before the Jags have can beat
the Titans and the Texans can beat the
Colts obviously with CJ stra back I mean
I wouldn't even put up the chance bills
this is a must win for you uh go out and
take it um Josh you've been playing
lights out and and go get what you
deserve man go prove people wrong um way
to bounce back in your season they're
streaking at the right time um they're
getting hot They just won four straight
and then you know obviously um I want to
give a big shout out and prayers to my B
my dog Bradley chub and xaven Howard man
the Dolphins missed two big ones I mean
this is just terrible ter a 11 sacks
leading league and with six Force
fumbles um and he plays last lights out
against us man and it's just TR truly
sad to see the
injuries um the injuries that's going
down right now man this is just and it's
just sad bro you see the quarterbacks
you see elite players just keep going
down this year and uh it it just makes
you think like what's going on uh the
way he dropped I mean it it's just truly
sad and uh you know we just going to
send a quick prayer to Bradley chub cuz
uh you you hate to see a great rusher
like him uh you know you know Fallout
like that especially how well he's been
playing and where his teams they just
lost they lost Jaylen Phillips and
Bradley chub two of their best Edge
rushers uh this year so heartbreaking
for Miami um hopefully they find a way
to bounce back and hopefully find a way
to get jayen wad back on the back on the
field um because he's out right now with
Xavier Howard uh this extremely sex for
Miami some of their best players are out
with injuries uh towards the end of the
season and you kind of hate to see that
Trend right the injuries the um the
loses because you know you kind of want
to start building up you know strong
wins heading in the playoffs and uh it
just seems like they just keep losing
people um which is bad so uh you're
going to count for people late in the
season to have to step up who may not
have been seeing a lot of playtime um
and that and that sucks so you know I'm
hoping everyone stay healthy everyone uh
gets excited you know it's one more week
left of NFL football before playoffs so
you know it's about to get real intense
it's about to get real exciting uh I
think this season went by very fast and
you know let's just let's just finish
the year off strong uh we're going into
a new year so I hope this new year
starts off
right so let's get straight into it
getting hot when it matters the bills
have lost and their last loss was in OT
against the Eagles they have gone on to
win four straight the Eagles have lost
four the last five games since they beat
the bills what does this mean for the
Eagles the Eagles last lost moved us
into first place in the NFC east and
gave the 49ers the number one
seed you could say what is going on
right um you know a lot one of my
teammates said it's better to learn when
you win to learn when you lose and I
think what's going on right now is the
same mistakes that Philly was making uh
when they won they never corrected them
um uh when they won and when they lost
they're just like well uh this should be
corrected this could be fixed so
something internally going on for sure
I'm definitely going to count on and
lean on to their leaders to make things
change um you know and and you always
want to start building you never want to
start losing confidence in your
teammates and your coaches around this
time this is when you're supposed to
come together you're supposed to build
their team chemistry you're supposed to
lock in just a little bit more um
because you know how important playoffs
is you know how important everyone needs
to be locked in everyone needs to
cherish these small wins small wins big
wins you can't Overlook anyone um
because it's just so
important um and everyone says playoffs
are about teams to go on high streaks
does the and peing at the right Point
does that really matter and I think it
does uh c teams that winning Super Bowl
the Ravens lost four to five final games
in 2009 Saints lost the last three games
uh in 2008 uh Cardinals lost four the
last six so it it's an extremely
important lesson because I think you do
need to lose to learn but Al but also
you need to win too so I think it's
important you need to learn how to go
through tough victories uh big victories
it's all about staying neutral in the
sense of winning um and that's I think
the Eagles are going to be fine I think
they're going to win a game or two and
it's going to be a tense battle uh and
playoffs but they definitely going to
have to learn and grow from their
mistakes and get better and try not to
play individually uh get everyone going
um I know there's a lot of frustration
usually with frustration it builds feud
feud and frustration never go against
each other and then you you don't want
people turn against each other and then
then there's like select grouping and
you see the toxicity in most locker
rooms and I'm specifically talking about
the Eagles locker room it's toxicity and
they start grouping oh well me and you
are playing well and they're playing
trash uh I don't even know why he's here
and things like that and they need to
play better the point of finger the
point of finger is like kids we're grown
men we're playing at a Le high level
Sport and you know teams just need to
come together and that's the best way
you know the best way to jail is to
believe in each other and I think that's
what a lot of teams and including Eagles
just need right now just need a jail and
I think the biggest factors you know a
leader like Darius Slay not there man
Darius slay uh I think people really
don't look at his leadership and what he
brings to the Eagles as high but I think
people should take notice of that uh cuz
I think he's a great leader man he's a
great person and just missing that type
of leader really shows dividends into
your team but let's get into college
football there was a lot of job in
college football both games came toown
to the last play and the roseb Michigan
beat Alabama 27 to 20 um did I agree
with Alabama's final play on Fourth and
goal yes and no I just feel like in that
position it was a l
snap Ben for the doubt you hate to see
that but I just feel like you got to
make an attempt in the air I feel like
they kind of knew uh especially the way
Bama's defense were playing they wanted
to run the ball they wanted to keep
things they ran it uh pretty much every
down in a row uh I just believe you got
to put it into one of your uh skill
weapons hands your quarterback can't
always do it all he had that one great
QB run to get him the first and goal
goal um but you just can't keep it in
hands you got to at least make one pass
keep him honest and I and I just didn't
see that and he did make the one big
pass on second down which got him the
first and uh third and goal I mean first
and goal on the three uh so it's very
interesting to see why they did that but
my biggest takeaway was Blake Corum uh I
mean that kid is a baller bro like he is
straight up baller um I think he's going
to be a Ste in the draft wherever he
goes I hope he does not go into the NFC
East unless it's the C boys um he's
obviously a kid unbelievable work ethic
unbelievable uh Talent Vision uh jump
cut extremely talented man I think uh
Blake Corin is going to be a gem a dime
in this league and uh I think he has a
chance if not to be national champions
in the next couple weeks because I think
this is going to be a great game between
Washington and uh uh Michigan and the
Sugar Bowl Washington beat Texas uh 3731
uh Michael pennick I been knew Michael
pennix was a baller um I played against
him twice in Indiana and he was always
making crazy throws uh balling out the
only reason why he wasn't dominant at
Indiana is because uh the year that we
played him and beat him uh he chores
acl's I think he had two ACL injuries um
but I'm finally see he's at Washington
around great weapons uh great
coordinator cuz he's always been a
Hooper I don't think anyone ever who
went against Michael penck ever thought
he was bad I mean I played against this
kid a couple times and he's always been
uh monstrous and he actually upset uh
Penn State the year we was top ranked I
think it was the first game we went down
to Indiana he beat us at Indiana I mean
the kids always been a monster always
been making great throws Elite throws uh
on the money and it really doesn't
surprise me uh and his performance there
you know over 400 yards two TDS I mean
he's a Hooper I mean bro Michael pennick
I think he should be uh at I think he
should be a top he should be a first
round pick I don't see how you let him
fall uh I don't think you should let him
fall I think if I had a comparison to
him I would say a lot uh reminds me a
lot of Dak guy who can make any throw on
the field uh great pres can put it right
up the scam if you want I mean bro
Michael pennick is a straight baller um
in the national championship who do I
want to take it it's hard for me to take
because I saw Washington struggle a
little bit against the Run game and that
Blake Chrome and that Michigan's
offensive line and the way I seen
Michigan's dline dominate bazo line it
really it it it's really gonna be close
I want to Edge Michigan um just the way
what I seen from Michigan's defensive
front and their offensive front I mean
they just been so dominant uh these last
couple years and in these playoff
games but Michael penck those receivers
and him and the way I seen him evade
pressure and still make those Elite
throws it it's going to come off to the
strength of Michael penck and it's going
to come off to the strength of that
front seven um but man I think this is
going to be Michigan's hardest challenge
for the people uh in the backend I don't
think uh Michigan seen a set of
receivers like that you know besides
Marvin Harrison and of course Ohio State
always has great receivers but I don't
think they seen a connection like how uh
Michael penx and those kids got over in
Washington
um it's going to be a close game I I'm
tempted to say Michigan just because
it's big 10 um in that front but Michael
penck the way he's been playing this
year um second in the highs man those
receivers man it's going to be close
it's going to be close I think it's
going to be a really good game um and
you just can't Overlook Washington um
they've been surprising everyone so I'm
going to sit down I'm going to take
Washington if I'm going to take a BET
right now I want to take Washington
um because how good they've been playing
and they've been able to win a lot of
close games they've been finding ways to
win games Oregon Texas like they held up
in a lot of good games and Michigan is
ah jayou Jordan Lewis I'm sorry I'm
going Washington I'm I got to take him
I'm taking Washington man I'm taking
Washington um you know I got to take
Washington um man it's going to be it's
going to be a crazy game I can't wait to
see it uh what should the Bears do let's
get into that what should the Bears do
this is the current draft
order
honestly if I'm the Bears I'm keeping
Justin Fields the people in Chicago when
Justin Fields
um he's been getting better and better
each season um they're chaning they want
Justin Fields their team still wants
Justin Fields um Justin Fields stats and
obviously he missed for four games he
has over 2,000 yards 16 touchdowns nine
interceptions um DJ Morris had a new
career high and receiving yards I think
you allow the commanders to trade up
they got picked two you allow them to
trade it up um can we see that draft
order again um you allow them to trade
up you allow them to trade up I believe
the Bears also have another pick uh
later in the draft they have two first
where's the Bears second pick that's why
I want to know where's the be second
pick you allowed them to trade up so now
you're getting even more draft Capital
if that means you get another first
round pick or you get a second round
pick that's quality players that you
could get they have pick at number 10
right if I'm if I'm mistaken right you
can still you could trade back you could
still sit at number two and that's the
question do you want to what do you want
to do I think there's a lot of great
receivers in this class if you're
talking about receiver to compliment DJ
Moore uh Mooney still been playing great
um but you you look at this you say you
want them to get Marvin Harrison but
Keon Coleman is an elite wide receiver
you going to have DOS coming out and you
got the kid from LSU there's four great
receivers in this draft that they can
still get they can still accomplish um
so you don't necessarily need Marvin
Harrison but there is the offensive
tackle especially the one out of Penn
State Olu that protect Justin's left
side you still had a lot of o o line
trouble so you can still get a lot of
draft Capital let Washington trade up
get their franchise guy because you have
a franchise guy um and because you also
have to realize when you take a
quarterback from number one and you
don't change the
circumstances let's look at the history
of first round picks that was taking
number one um besides burrow I don't
without the weapons I don't see another
guy that really changed the program
around you see Trevor Lawrence is still
struggling um you see we we just just
look at the history of it you know the
first picks Baker Mayfield kind of is on
different team teams right now um I'm
not saying the be situation is a bad
situation but it's not the greatest
situation I think Justin's been doing a
great job in that turmoil he's still
winning games he's still playing good
every every quarterback has his bad day
every every quarterback um obviously
doesn't play great all the time but
Justin is keep getting better and I
don't think we should go away from them
they should have won a lot more games
than they did this year you can get the
draft capital and you can still keep
growing with him I think Justin should
be should be and
Chicago next year with another Elite
wide receiver to compliment DJ Moore and
another o lineman I mean this would be
great and Caleb Williams still be first
overall off the Washington trade up
which I think Washington will trade up
uh if not and you trade him to
Washington like I still think that's
great I think he he'll turn up with
Terry McLaren uh Jan Dodson Curtis
Samuel they have some great um they have
some great players in Washington but I
do think the Bears should keep Justin
Fields um and you know it it's cool you
know I just think I just don't think you
should move on from the history number
one quarter number one picks at
quarterback don't turn out that well uh
and that's just the reality of it and
there's a lot of struggle you they look
what the Panthers did to give up for
Bryce young and they didn't do a great
job putting a lot of around him like
they didn't put a lot around him they
they picked up guys like Adam th who's a
great player GJ Clark he's a good but
the the o line struggles the the team
struggled they gave up a lot to get him
and they're it's going to be hard for
him to climb back up so I think they
should continue to keep getting draft
capital and keep Justin fields and
building this team around him because I
think he still can be special in this
league I'll be taking your questions
before we wrap this up so drop them now
and I get to them at the end of the show
and obviously we're going into week 18
Cowboys Comm manage the final week of
the regular season
um this this is for the division we have
a chance to be the number two seed in
the playoffs game on the line a chance
to play two home games if we win
obviously the first round uh extremely
important game we know how well we play
at home we have to be Road Warriors we
have to be dominant Cowboys Nation I
need y'all to show up to Washington we
need to take over uh we need to take
over Washington man we need to take over
we need to make this feel like a home
game we need to go back home we need y'
support and love and playoffs and Dallas
we need to take over it's time Cowboys
Nation I'm asking you to stand up one
more time travel to Washington Sunday
400 p.m. we got to take over Washington
we got to take over FedEx because guess
what we have a chance to play at home
and you know how good we are to play at
home so uh coach Michael car said let's
be honest the playoffs have already
stared I couldn't agree more this is the
boiling week this is the end week it's
going to be super exciting it's going to
be super super exciting uh you know to
get this game over with and obviously
get the focus but we got to focus on
this game uh to get that number two seed
two and obviously win the division um is
going to be uh super exciting and a
great blessing to win the division all
we've been through the injuries the
adversity um and it's going to be well
worth it because you just never know
what can happen um and we D sure didn't
know this was a possibility uh and we
have a chance so we have to do
that uh and you know it it's going to be
super fun obviously Washington and
Cowboys always a great game uh you know
it's always back and forth Feud
obviously Bad Blood uh obviously not the
year Washington planned on having but
it's going to be a great game um but let
let's get to some questions in the chat
and uh and let's just get it started uh
a lot of questions about dvin uh
thoughts on dvin cook obviously dvin
cook has been U they mutually agreed on
release D Shan play for a playoff team
can he help a playoff team absolutely uh
dvin cook went into a system where you
know they didn't really know how to
feature them I think it was more of the
namesake uh obviously they didn't know
how well Bree was going to come back
obviously Bree Hall came back well off
the ACL injury and they just felt like
Bree is their long-term guy so they
didn't utilize him uh and dvin just
looking opportunity to display his
talents I still think dvin can be an
elite back Elite player and you know I
think he could benefit any playoff team
he could benefit the Cowboys he could
benefit uh the ners he could benefit any
team and playoffs still an elite player
uh for six years straight he averaged
over a th000 total yards I mean he's
always been a great back you know so
dalin's always been that guy you know uh
thoughts on Aiden Hudson I think Aiden
Hudson's a really good player uh he
bought out last week um and you know you
know he he's always been a dog you know
ever since he came into the league as a
rookie uh always made a lot of noise uh
made a statement and uh you know keep
going Aiden um we saw a CD fumble at the
one yard line do you think a fumble
through the end zone should be a
Touchback I don't think they should
change that rule because uh you know
it's a great opportunity for defenses to
make plays uh the ball got a little
loose on CD and that Defender made a
great play and they got a touch deck
that was a game-changing play um and if
it's not we probably score right there
and you know that might change the game
anyway so I still do think that they
should keep that rule uh just because it
it goes on the ball carries and make
sure they're being tight and firm with
the ball cuz we're always looking for
them late punch outs you see that uh a
couple years ago with Trayvon Diggs with
K metf on that long play uh just secure
ball Carri needs to be better in
crossing the goal line Point Bank
period uh what was where was your
favorite place to play this season not
Dallas uh my favorite place to play I
would I obviously sof far I think sof
far got one of the best stadiums
obviously it's newly built uh the Rams
and the Chargers play there and I think
that's one of the best stadiums in the
NFL for sure um great Turf uh great you
know it's always electric there uh
there's a lot of Cowboys fans in LA and
uh it's always a great turnout uh let's
get this NFC East this weekend 100% uh
it's going to be a great game I can't to
wait to see y'all there Cowboys Nation
uh super excited to get down there and
obviously clinch the NFC East uh and I
can't wait to do it and share with you
all so guess what see you in Washington
that's a wrap for your boy on the edge
uh live in your Bleacher Report app
thank you for tuning in to the
edge
he